how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu happy new year's eve and happy new
years to everybody i'm sure everybody is
glad to put 2020 behind us
and start 2021 where we're actually
going to be getting marvel movies and
shows the drive spell for marvel content
is finally
over and i have a lot of exciting videos
planned for 2021 so
if you love marvel be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of them
right now we need to talk about the
teaser 4 spider-man 3 the teaser for the
eternals and
shang-chi now we'll start with
spider-man 3 because i know everybody is
very eagerly awaiting that teaser for
those of you who are not aware
sony executive camilla pacheco did
promise during a convention that was
held about three months ago
that we would be getting the teaser for
spider-man 3 a first
look before the end of the year she
actually specifically said that we would
get a first
look of spider-man 3 this december well
there's only
one day left and it's not here yet i
want to be hopeful
and say that it's coming out today but i
don't think it is and the reason for
that
is from what we've heard is because toby
mcguire hasn't
officially signed on for the film yet
from what we know he has committed to
the film but the final paperwork is not
done yet and according to daniel richman
sony doesn't actually want to show
anything for the movie until they have
andrew garfield
toby maguire and tom holland all set for
the spider-verse movie
now of course there is a chance that
they could surprise us today and
announce a title or show us a poster of
all three spider-man
something along those lines but as far
as a teaser trailer
is concerned i don't think we're going
to be getting one but the title reveal
should be coming very very soon and as
soon as they lock down toby it looks
like that's when we're going to be
getting it so it should be soon but
unfortunately
even though sony themselves did say it
was coming this december
it doesn't look like we'll be getting it
this december and unfortunately the same
goes for the eternals teaser
and the shanxi teaser marvel studios
recently announced that they were doing
an event with the streaming service
billy billy
and there they said they were going to
show us a glimpse of what's to come
in 2021 now of course everybody thought
that because they said
a glimpse of what's to come in 2021 they
were going to show us
some footage related to the eternals in
shanghai but unfortunately that was not
the case as the event was this morning
and we did not get any new footage
what we got was a musical number and
orchestra playing the avengers theme
they showed silhouettes of the original
six avengers and then up top of the
screen
they showed the mandarin logos for
shangshi and the legend of the ten rings
black widow and the eternals so
according to marvel studios sharing a
glimpse of what's to come is showing
the logos of the movies that are
actually coming in 2021
technically they did show us a glimpse
of what's to come in 2021 just not what
we expected
especially after coming off of disney's
investor day where they showed us a ton
of new information and footage for
upcoming phase 4.
now we've already seen a lot of black
widow we got a teaser trailer and
an official trailer for it not to
mention some special looks as well so we
probably won't be getting anything new
for that
but xiang chi comes out the middle of
next year which means we should be
expecting the teaser for it relatively
soon
what marvel's plan could be is to attach
it with the release of the one division
series coming out on january 15th
this is not in any way confirmed but is
something they could be considering
doing
and unfortunately as far as the eternals
teaser trailer is concerned they might
sit on it a little bit more since it's
coming out november of next year
but disney is also having another
investor's day in february so perhaps
they're going to show us a bunch of new
trailers and footage like they did in
this past one
it's unfortunate that we didn't get the
teasers today and hopefully we get
something spider-man 3 related very soon
and if i hear anything i'll be sure to
update everybody so be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
twitter and instagram and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you